bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce see logos aujourd'hui je vous
retrouve pour une vidéo un peu plus posé
et détente je vous ai préparé une petite
liste des films des livres des vidéos
youtube des artistes des musiques que
j'ai écouté au cours de ce premier
trimestre 2021 en espérant que ça vous
fasse découvrir quelques petites choses
et que ça vous donne envie d'élargir un
peu votre horizon culturel
alors en ce qui concerne les livres j'ai
pas lu énormément je cours de supprimer
trimestre du moins pas dans une logique
de littérature plaisir puisque ben je
suis en thèse est que je suis en plus en
première année thèse donc je lis
énormément de clown et scientifique de
livres académiques et s'est du coup les
livres un peu plaisir passe au second
plan
et j'ai quand même lu plusieurs livres
surtout dans le bateau pour aller au
travail
j'avoue que c'est un cadre plus agréable
pour lire du coup le premier livre dont
je vous parlais c'est chavirer de lola
lafon alors le balafon déjà c'est une
autre issue que j'aimais bien
j'avais lu d'elle la petite communiste
qui ne souriait jamais au sujet de nadia
comaneci kenji menace qui a marqué la
discipline et c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse
donc bref j'étais déjà un petit peu
séduite par le dal à fond et se trouve
que chavirer m'a passionné je les lui en
deux trois jours je ne m'en séparer plus
mais vraiment c'est un superbe ouvrage
un roman passionnant qui dans lequel on
entre sans problème qui a qui abordent
des sujets extrêmement lourd donc voilà
je vais pas forcément de métal sur la
question mais ça traite de violences
sexuelles sur des mineurs et surtout de
l'organisation de réseaux permettant de
maintenir cette violence sexuelle c'est
très bien des crises et voilà le piège
un peu dans le canton les romans qui
parle de ces sujets c'est d'adopter
finalement un point de vue qui est celui
plutôt de l'agresseur que je suis la
victime est là
vraiment ne se détache jamais du point
de vue de cette jeune fille qui grandit
qui évoluent dans les milieux en plus de
la danse etc
donc si c'est des thématiques qui vous
intéresse c'est un super moment très
facile d'accès pour un public assez
large si notamment souvent vous sentez
que vous avez un peu du mal à lire et
cetera c'est vraiment un roman qui à la
page facile quoi on est vraiment
embarqué dans l'histoire rapidement donc
je vous recommande le deuxième livre
dont je vous parlais c'est un essai il
s'agit d un casa bleus de rachid 0 qui
j'en ai déjà parlé dans une de mes
vidéos je pense sur les recommandations
pour débuter la sociologie et c'est un
essai que j'attends avec beaucoup
d'impatience parce que j'ai travaillé
pendant un an pour les services de
l'éducation nationale et que janet
j'étais analystes réseaux sociaux donc
je voyais évidemment passer les tweets
de rachid zerrouki qui est lui-même
professeur et voilà c'est un essai sur
son expérience de prof en segpa dans des
classes spécialisées dans en plus un
collège réputé difficile dans les
quartiers nord de marseille
et c'est un essai plein d'humanité très
intéressant qui est très accessible même
si on ne connaît pas forcément le milieu
de l'éducation nationale et cetera
c'est vrai assez bien écrit c'est pas
révolutionnaire moi c'est pas avec un
apport théorique etc mais c'est un beau
récit d'expériences et je vous conseille
j'ai aussi lu comme un empire dans un
empire donc le dernier roman d'alice
zeniter et je dois vous avouer que je
n'ai pas trop aimé voilà je pense que
c'est un livre qui a été quand même
assez bien accueilli par la critique
mais moi j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
m'accrocher au personnage en fait c'est
un roman qui avait un peu tout pour me
plaire parce que ça permet à la fois de
féminisme d'action féministe mais aussi
de politique c'est deux mondes dans
lesquels j'ai évolué de par mes études
et cetera et ben voilà ça avait tout
pour me plaire mais ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné sur moi alors je sais pas
assez dans la construction des
personnages où il
qui était presque gens retrouveraient
pour moi parce qu'il ressemble à
certains de mes camarades de promo et
l'autre qui un personnage qui n'a pas de
nom
du coup je pense que ça m'a empêché de
me représenter ce personnage dans mon
esprit voilà je sais pas après ça
remonte qui est extrêmement bien
documenté sur les enjeux de cyber
sécurité également ses il ya en toile de
fond toute la mouvance des gilet jaune
et cetera mais moi vraiment j'ai dû
m'accrocher pour le finir ce livre j'ai
pas trop je trouve que l'élément de la
rencontre des deux personnages qui sont
écrits depuis le début arrive très tard
dans livre que finalement il ne se prive
pas le grand chamboulement qu'on
imaginait et voilà c'est pas mes favoris
mais bon en tout cas je vous laisse vous
faire votre propre avis j'ai profité de
mes trajets quotidiens en bateau pour
relire sorcière demont à cholet je les
lui à sa sortie donc je crois que
c'était en 2017 et j'avais l'impression
dans longtemps parler de plein de
manières différentes et je suis mais en
fait c'est ce que je suis passé à côté
quelque chose avec ce bouquin et se
trouve complètement gelé revue pour mon
assuré ça m'a permis de me rappeler de
certains éléments mais surtout ce que
j'ai vraiment apprécié c'est de pouvoir
relire un essai qui est
très documenté avec énormément de
références bibliographiques mais qui est
facile à lire et en tant que doctorante
ça m'a vraiment permis de me rappeler ce
que c'est que la fluidité en écriture et
que c'est pas parce que maintenant je
suis censé écrire des contenus
académiques très complexes et que je
dois en oublier le style et la fluidité
est resté voir accessible dans
l'écriture est vraiment ça a été une
belle leçon de style je pense que mon à
cholet elle est vraiment inégalé à ce
sujet de réussira à vulgariser mais sans
perdre en qualité scientifique et voilà
c'est plus cet aspect dire que je vais
retenir du livre pour cette seconde
lecture
dans la série des lectures féministe
j'ai également lu la cause des femmes de
gisèle halimi donc l'avocate qui est
décédé il y a quelques mois
eh bien écoutez c'était un très bon
livre je m'y attendais je pense que
voilà c'est ça il est précédé par sa
réputation
c'est un excellent livre toute la partie
sur le procès de bobigny m'a vraiment
fasciné voilà moi c'est une époque que
je n'ai pas connu de mon vivant
donc il ya vraiment cette plongée dans
l'action on a l'impression d'y être en
temps réel et puis tout voilà c'est
cette atmosphère des années 70-80 de la
sortie la guerre d'algérie des premiers
grands procès sur la médiatiser on va
dire dans lesquelles il y avait des
enjeux sur l'avortement et la
dépénalisation de l'avortement sur le
viol etc et de voir comment cette
avocate a construit son parcours en tant
que femme et féministe bah c'est très
inspirant c'est voilà il ya je ne sais
même pas quoi vous dire d'autre c'est
vraiment pour moi c'est préférable
d'histoire et c'est vraiment tout à fait
passionnant et le dernier livre dont je
vous parlais c'est là ma zone verte
délice thibault alors cet essai
vraiment assez original puisqu'il s'agit
d'un roman inspiré de la vie de
françoise d'eaubonne qui est une
intellectuelle
je considère comme l'inventrice de
l'écoféminisme alors françoise
d'eaubonne
c'est une intellectuelle que j'ai
croisés dans mes études universitaires
quand ça devait être vers 2015 quand
j'ai commencé à travailler en études de
genre et que je me suis penché sur les
questions de l'éco féminisme c'est
vraiment une référence sur la voilà les
origines de l'uqo féministe et pourtant
son nom est vite oublié et on parle pas
forcément beaucoup d'elle et au delà de
l'écoféminisme c'est quand même une
femme de lettres et une intellectuelle
majeure du siècle dernier et c'est assez
incroyable de voir la quantité de livres
qu'elle a écrit pour en fait la
postérité qu'elle connaît qui est
vraiment pas à la hauteur de son travail
d'ailleurs la fin de ces livres ne sont
plus publiés n'hésitez pas là c'est
c'est aussi je pense pour ça que lise
thibault un peu pris les devants et
publier ce livre qui est tout à fait
passionnant puisqu'il y a en fait une
énorme recherche d'archivés c'est
presque un travail de chercheur ou l
heure est construit en quelque sorte
cette biographie n'est qu' un roman 6 et
est en fait c'est très fluide du coup à
la lecture on s'attache à la fois à
hélices thiébaut qui reste une
narratrice très présente et à la fois à
françoise d'eaubonne qui est quand même
un personnage très particulier et très
attachant et je trouve que c'est aussi
j'allais dire rendre à césar ce qui est
à césar mais on va plutôt dire rendre à
cléopâtre ce qui est à cléopâtre feu je
trouve que ça la replace dans toute la
production littéraire et intellectuelle
dans toutes les innovations qu'elle a
apportée dans ce contexte encore une
fois des années 70-80 extrêmement dense
au niveau intellectuel avec aussi les
premières féministes matérialiste qui
ont structuré le champ disciplinaire des
études de genre en france
voilà il ya toute la structuration
les mouvements homosexuels et lesbiennes
le mouvement de libération des femmes
donc le mlf
mais avant ça il ya aussi sa petite
expérience de résistance dans la seconde
guerre mondiale la guerre d'algérie et
du coup elle a été aussi à la pointe du
mouvement écologiste avec une bombe
qu'elle a quand même posé devant une
centrale nucléaire
voilà donc voilà c'est une figure qui
est extrêmement inspirante qui est
beaucoup plus complexe que ce qu'on
voudrait laisser croire voilà des femmes
militantes
on donne beaucoup à françoise d'eaubonne
et j'espère vraiment que l'amazone verte
d'alice thibault va permettre de
relancer un petit peu la visibilité deux
ouvrages moi ya vraiment un roman
qu'elle a écrit que j'aimerais beaucoup
lire apparemment c'est dans une trilogie
et c'est les bergères de l'apocalypse je
crois qui est en fait une espèce de
dystopie où les les femmes auraient pris
le pouvoir en tuant tous les hommes en
fait dans un espèce de révolution
féministe à l'extrême et avec des
personnages du conte féminin très
violents etc
et du coup elle imagine tout ce monde
olizane n'existe plus puis la question
de la survivance de l'espèce etc bref je
je suis extrêmement intrigué par deux
écrit de françoise d'eaubonne qui sont
donc des écrits littérature que je n'ai
pas du tout lu et je vous conseille
vraiment de découvrir cette femme
totalement incroyable est extraordinaire
alors maintenant nous allons passer à la
catégorie des films donc pour commencer
je vais vous parler d'un film turc
il s'agit de bnl minable alors ce film
en fait moi si vous voulez j'habite en
turquie j'aime beaucoup la turquie je
suis évidemment très intéressés par la
culture anatolienne etc
pour autant je dois avouer que les
séries turques les films turcs c'est
juste pas du tout mon truc j'ai vraiment
du mal à accrocher avec le style avec
les intrigues avec la manière dont les
rebondissements sont un ex terra
j'essaye de me forcer mais
vraiment ça ne ça ne passe pas et
pourtant j'ai trouvé un film qui m'a
fait changer d'avis et qui est du coup
je vous recommande si vous n'êtes pas du
tout habitués ou sensibles au cinéma
turc est anatolien donc bnm il elle qui
a un mot un petit peu anciens pour dire
internationale c'est un film vraiment
intéressant pour ceux qui connaissent
pas le bon axe de dieu que ça se passe
après un coup d'état militaire qui a eu
lieu dans les années 80 et où de
nombreux opposants de gauche est
également des opposants kurdes sont
assassinés donc on est dans ce contexte
de tensions politiques dans un village
et des jeunes commencent aussi à
s'imprégner de ce soulèvement politique
face à la une une armée omniprésente et
dieu est en fait c'est un film qui a
donc comme beaucoup de films turcs ce
côté romand ce qui est très présent
politique également très présent mais
voilà c'est accessible
on y apprend beaucoup je trouve sur la
culture anatolienne c'est très bien
amené on est après également beaucoup
sur l' influence des des politiques des
idéologies de gauche communistes
soviétiques et c'est en turquie et
notamment parmi les populations kurdes
et cetera c'est vraiment bien amené j'ai
versé ma petite larme à la fin objectif
atteint ensuite dans le cadre de la
préparation de ma vidéo sur le système
carcéral dont qui s'appelle la prison
est-elle obsolète en hommage à angela
davis
j'ai vu trois films qui traitent des
sujets du système carcéral américain et
du mouvement black panthers aux états
unis alors le premier c'est un
documentaire qui s'appelle ciotti ns
donc c'est sur netflix en référence au
13e amendement
c'est un très bon documentaire en fait
c'est pas vraiment de
l'analyse du réseau d'oppression
spécifique qui est mis en place contre
les afro américains aux états unis pour
expliquer leur omniprésence dans les
prisons américaines
donc voilà c'est plutôt vraiment cette
rhétorique de partir de l'analyse du
racisme pur comprend le système carcéral
il y à angela davis notamment qui en qui
intervient dans ce documentaire c'est
très intéressant c'est également
déprimant mais c'est la réalité du monde
dans lequel nous vivons
voilà c'est vraiment un documentaire que
je vous recommande si vous êtes
intéressés par ces questions
ensuite le deuxième film que j'ai
visionné dans le cadre de cette vidéo
c'est chicago stephen donc c'est aussi
son aile fixe c'est un film qui retrace
le procès qui a été menée contre des
opposants politiques à la suite d'une
manifestation qui a dégénéré et au cours
de laquelle le leader des black panthers
fait mt étaient également jugés alors
qu'ils n'avaient aucun rapport avec
l'événement en question c'est un vous
voyez les finis qui se présente sur un
procès où on est quand même c'est dans
le huis clos du procès mais on est
sortis de temps en temps pour des flash
back pour voir ce qui se passe en dehors
de la salle d'audience et serra j'ai
adoré ce film voilà j'étais c'est un
petit peu peut-être dur au début si on
connaît pas du tout l'histoire
américaine le contexte de l'époque
mais en fait il met bien en place tous
les personnages et on s'attache
extrêmement vite on comprend vraiment
les intérêts de chacun c'est très bien
écrit voilà vraiment un très bon film
politique qui est nous fait plonger dans
l'ambiance même hippie et cetera de
l'époque avec beaucoup de sarcasme mais
en temps voilà je pense une espèce de
réalité crue sur ce qui s'est passé à ce
procès puisque ce procès a vraiment
existé
voilà un film dur aussi puisque je vais
pas vous spoiler si je ne sais pas
l'histoire de certains de ces activistes
mais voilà c'est un très bon film
vraiment je vous le recommande les yeux
fermés et enfin le dernier film que j'ai
visionné sur la question c'est joss and
black messia qui se concentre sur
l'histoire de fred hampton donc comme je
vous le disais un des leaders du
mouvement black panther aux états unis
où ma baffe l'ademe tonnes c'est assez
récent mon intérêt pour pour lui et en
fait c'est quelqu'un comme qui me
fascine parce que il était un activiste
du cou qui était extrêmement jeune qui
avait 21 ans quand il a percé et qui se
reçoit avec une aura absolument
extraordinaire sur tout un mouvement
voilà deux de désobéissance civile les
deux luttes pour la reconnaissance des
droits des personnes noires aux états
unis et j'étais extrêmement déçu par ce
film je alors déjà par là par exemple
dans chicago seven fly down town est
vraiment très bien représenté je trouve
comme une personne qui a beaucoup
d'aplomb qui est un très grand orateur
est en fait dans le film black mafia
bon déjà le titre aurait dû vous mettre
la puce à l'oreille mais il apparaît
presque en en espèces de deux rappeurs
flippant dans au début du film c'est à
dire que on n'a plus peur de lui qu'on a
envie de le suivre de respecter quoi il
a les yeux tout ensanglanté il
il a un rythme de parole un accent très
particulier alors qu'au contraire
fred hampton dans les archives qu'on a
de lui avait une voie très claire un
accent très classique un peu comme
angela davis peut avoir et du coup je
trouve ça assez caricatural monsois je
me suis dit ok et en fait pour moi tout
le film est un échec c'est à dire qu'on
dirait limite un film de propagande pour
qu'on aime pas vraiment fred hampton à
la fin quoi c'est à dire que même quand
il ya des personnages qui sont tués
assassiné délibérément par la police on
n'a pas de compassion
donc c'est vraiment un effet du film qui
montre que même des gens qui vivent dans
la misère qui ne sont pas vraiment
solidaire qui sont plus dans des
réactions enfin je sais bail
quelque chose de très dérangeant dans ce
film je trouve qu'il ya pas voilà qui ne
respectent pas forcément inexactitudes
historiques ou du moins qu'il ne fait
pas du tout honneur aux personnages bien
réels desquels il traite est en fait
tout ça d'ailleurs s'est vu sous l'angle
en fait d'un jeune noir qui est recruté
par le fbi pour infiltrer le mouvement
des black panthers et continuer
d'informer le fbi et la cia
je ne sais plus les deux sont brefs
en gros vous a compris un espion qui
s'infiltrent il est lui-même nord
américain du coup la question c'est est
ce qu'il va se laisser convaincre par
l'idéologie qui est en train de naître
du côté des black panther où est-ce
qu'il va continuer à divulguer les infos
voilà pour moi pourrons aussi une
histoire réelle apparemment c'est à dire
que cette personne et même montré dans
son vrai visage
à la fin du film
comment dire pour moi c'est peu probable
dans le sens où en fait toute la partie
complexe de comment il est recruté et
comment ils arrivent pour autant à
s'infiltrer dans les blocs moteurs aussi
proche de fred hampton et compagnie
c'est pas clair c'est pas bien expliqué
ça va trop vite on comprend pas les
réelles motivations donc c'est pas
crédible
et comme ça ce point de départ n'est pas
crédible tout le reste du film se
construit un peu comme un géant aux
pieds d'argile et ça ne fonctionne pas
en fait bon vous l'aurez compris je n'ai
pas aimé ce film je vais pas disserter
pendant dix ans dessus mais il ya
beaucoup à dire et je trouve que c'est
même un peu inquiétant de voir qui est
des films américains qui sont produits
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont cette espèce de
volonté de noircir le tableau avec des
artifices alors que évidemment le
mouvement des black panthers
comme tout mouvement de lutte sociale et
politique mais pas parfait donc il ya
des choses à critiquer mais là c'est
vraiment comme une volonté de d'entacher
l'histoire et je trouve ça extrêmement
dérangeant bon j'ai vu plein d'autres
films d'ailleurs beaucoup qui n'était
pas au top mais je veux juste vous
parler d'un autre film pour remonter un
peu le niveau
c'est un film qui s'appelle stranger
than fiction qui a été dirigée par marc
forster
alors en fait pourtant je suis pas
forcément fan des films américains on a
un peu comédie américaine extra mais ce
film j'ai trouvé qu'il était vraiment
rafraîchissant
ne serait ce que par l'histoire et la
manière de les raconter on a en fait un
mec tout à fait lambda je crois qu'il
est inspecteur des impôts quelque chose
comme ça vraiment quelqu'un de très
rationnel de très mathématique dans sa
vie qui apparaît comme un personnage
extrêmement lisse est en fête et se met
à entendre une voix qui narre sa vie et
de fil en aiguille il va réaliser qu'il
est le personnage d'un livre qui est en
train d'être écrit et il va se mettre en
tête de rencontrer l'autre is de ce
livre voilà je trouve que c'est un film
super intéressant sur voile et
l'imbrication de la narration la
construction des personnages etc
j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est divertissant
c'est léger agréable à regarder
en fait c'est vraiment la narration fait
tout dans ce film c'est vraiment
agréable même une fois l'effet de
surprise un peu de comprendre qu'ils les
personnages arrivent passé on s'attache
encore à un changement qui le père dans
sa vie
sa volonté de vivre et sera donc voilà
un film tranquille pour le dimanche soir
on va dire et voilà pour les films mais
la chose finalement que je regarde le
plus ça reste et youtube
donc pour mes recommandations youtube
c'est trois derniers mois j'ai beaucoup
regardé les vidéos des artisans de
demain
alors je pense que vous devez connaître
quand même une très grosse chaîne
youtube mais au cas où et bien voilà
donc c'est une chaîne qui est tenu par
camille eliès qui sont des voyageurs
français qui ont un mode de vie nomade
un moment où dans le confinement
quand on avait vraiment un confinement
strict j'avais beaucoup de mal à
regarder leurs vidéos parce que ils
étaient entre le coup encore en mode
nomade
en fait ils vivent véhicules aménagés et
du coup il se baladait beaucoup il était
dehors etc etc une période où ça me
faisait du mal de voir qu'il y avait des
gens qui pouvaient encore se déplacer
mais j'ai pu retrouver petit à petit le
goût de regarder leurs vidéos et c'est
vraiment mais un travail d'une très
grande qualité audiovisuelle avec une
très belle narration leur but
à l'origine c'est quand même de se
déplacer pour aller à la rencontre de
personnes qui sont donc des artisans de
demain qui essaie de travailler un monde
meilleur
donc c'est plein d'optimisme de belles
initiatives et ils le montrent de plus
en plus comment ils s'organisent quelle
est leur vie quotidienne sur la route et
ils sont récemment retournées au
pakistan où se trouvaient leurs
véhicules depuis le début de la pandémie
et voilà je
j'aime beaucoup les suivre je vous
recommande vivement si vous avez envie
de voir d'autres décors et d'entendre
des personnes bienveillantes et agréable
à écouter
ensuite au niveau plus littéraire il ya
deux chaînes youtube dont littéraire que
j'apprécie beaucoup
une que je suis depuis des années c'est
la chaîne dans ta stévia donc elle a à
la fois une chaîne un petit peu général
donc en rester là mais aussi une chaîne
littéraire donc entassé ziani et ses
deux chaînes va à chaque fois qu'elle
sur une vidéo je la regarde ça fait
peut-être six sept huit ans que je la
suis quelqu'un qui je trouve section
extrêmement bien qui défendent des
opinions même quand
apparemment ça va un peu contre le sens
du courant et chaud que c'est toujours
très argumenté précis mais en même temps
elle a l'air de parler comme ça dans un
flot de de parole argumenté précisé
naturel c'est très agréable à entendre
en plus elle est professeur de
littérature donc de français au lycée
donc elle en parle aussi ça m'intéresse
beaucoup
elle parle de livres avec des thèmes
très originaux là sa dernière vidéo
c'est sur la littérature prolétarienne
japonaise clairement c'est quelque chose
je ne me serais jamais penchée de moi
même et là ça me fait rêver et voyager
bon malheureusement j'ai pas le temps de
lire tant que ça mais par exemple elle a
beaucoup insisté au cours des mois
dernier sur un livre qu'elle a apprécié
de littérature chinoise que j'ai acheté
et que j'ai hâte de commencer mais comme
c'est un gros pavé je vais toute attente
d'être un peu plus des tentes au niveau
de la thèse pour 1000 mètres et l'autre
chaîne intérieur que j'ai découvert
beaucoup plus récemment c'est celle de
marguerite au donc voilà une chaîne qui
parle de livres encore une fois avec une
passion débordante voie qui traverse
l'écran et on a mal à mal souvent je la
lui mme pendant que je fais autre chose
et je les écoute me balader où j'ai
envie de lire toute une bibliothèque
c'est vraiment très agréable à écouter
elle donne des avis toujours nuancé et
sincère voilà jeu j'aime beaucoup en
plus la teste des formats un peu
originaux donc comme de lire mille pages
en trois jours je crois c'est ça
récemment
donc voilà c'est si vous avez envie
d'être une petite bulle de littérature
et de bienveillance je vous conseille
aussi la chaîne de marcory tôt après au
niveau de la vulgarisation scientifique
il ya une chaîne qui pour moi fait
référence depuis plusieurs années donc
si vous ne la connaissez pas je vous
incite fortement à aller faire un tour
sur la chaîne des revues du monde qui
est animée par charles id danger moi
j'attends ce à dire sheridan d'heure
mais je crois qu'elle quel point mon
chat et danger bref donc qui est une
chaîne avec un angle plutôt archéologie
histoire
enfin pour moi la cites du travail est
vraiment professionnel c'est à dire
qu'on est dans une émission de
vulgarisation scientifique à la télé
c'est extrêmement de l'ain produit
toujours très intéressant très rythmée
des thèmes
très différent originaux enfin je suis
j'adore cette chaîne je regarde à chaque
fois la nouvelle vidéo quand elle sort
je vous recommande à 1000 %
ensuite il ya eu mieux tout buzz qui
fait des vidéos qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ce que je fais isabelle clara
victoria donc là encore je pense pas que
je fais découvrir grand chose mais bon
sait-on jamais c'est une vitesse qui est
spécialisé sur la question de mode de
seconde main vintage et caetera et voit
depuis quelques mois
oui ou voir depuis presque un an
peut-être elle documente la création de
sa friperie qui s'appelle longue
reliques et qui situés à paris et tout
ce chemin de l'entrepreneur avec en plus
de très belles images dans un univers
vintage on a besoin de voir paris mazet
70 quand on regarde cette vidéo c'est
vraiment très agréable chaud que c'est
une une femme qui est ambitieuse ça se
sent et bonjour zucca travaille beaucoup
et ça m'inquiète parfois un but pour
elle à travers mon écran mais des vidéos
qui sont du coup inspirante parce qu'on
voit quelqu'un qui a décidé de vivre de
sa passion qui s'en donne les moyens et
c'est super inspirant et enfin la
dernière chaîne youtube que je regarde
beaucoup ces temps ci c'est la chaîne de
lloyd langue qui est une vidéaste franco
mexicaine il me semble qui produit un
contenu de cuisine vegan elle a vraiment
mais tellement de recettes différentes
en plus des trucs qui sont très
accessibles même sens voilà avoir deux
d'ingrédients compliqué et c est là des
recettes pour tous les niveaux sucrés et
salés à chaque fois que j'ai reproduit
une de ses recettes assez valide à 100%
donc je recommande alors rapidement au
niveau de la musique j'ai pas découvert
beaucoup d'artistes ces derniers temps
donc j'espère revenir dans le prochain
bilan culturel avec un peu plus de
nouvelles infos mais je vous partage et
du coup les musiques que j'ai le plus
écouté les artistes que j'avais plus
écoutés du coup au cours du trimestre
dernier
alors les artistes qui m'ont les petits
accompagnés déjà il y à pommes qui est
une chanteuse que vous connaissez
sûrement ce qu'elle est quand même assez
connu ça fait vraiment des années que je
suis fan de cet artiste je trouve
qu'elle a des textes d'une poésie d'une
force rare qu'elle a une musicalité
incroyable ça me transporte totalement
va c'est une artiste que j'aime beaucoup
et j'avais des billets pour l avoir à
l'olympia douglas est reporté pour la
troisième fois en espérant que la
troisième sera la bonne voilà une
artiste formidable que je vous
recommande beaucoup j'ai beaucoup écouté
son dernier morceau
enfin jeudi dernier mais peut-être que
ça l'est plus maintenant mais quand
j'arrive en turquie est la sortie
grandiose qui est une chanson mais juste
sublime
donc je vous la recommande est en butte
au delà des chansons je trouve que c'est
une femme qui a une personnalité mais
tellement attachant talent a l'air
d'être une espèce de naïveté mais
adorable un temps à une artiste au
dessus du monde un temps dans le monde
parce qu'elle est clairement engagé
politiquement et séraphin bref ça n'a ni
queue ni tête que je suis en train de
raconter j'ai l'impression elle a
participé à une vidéo de bain
never never nevers oui bon il y avait
donc ben camélia jordana pomme et
camille combal
pour moi ça allait vraiment mais le truc
improbable parce que camélia jordana qui
est d'ailleurs que la chanteuse que
j'aime beaucoup aussi et pommes
elles sont amies voilà je sais assez
connu qu'un bref elle semble très bien
leur camille combal je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
et en fait j'ai passé je crois que ça
dure une heure mais c'est passé beaucoup
trop vite
vraiment ils sont partis dans plein de
discussions d'un peu de délirer tout et
c était interactions d'être dans un
moment entre amis à les écouter plein de
bonne humeur de rire oh là là
franchement c'est la vidéo je vous la
met en garde un faux et je vous la
recommande pas ce que c'est
c'est juste agréable des ententes
divaguer sur des sujets rien à voir les
uns que les autres
bref au top ensuite j'ai encore et
toujours écouté le même album en boucle
de in jazz qui est un groupe donc de
musique anatolienne avec donc en
prédominance le saz donc le bats lama
qui est un instrument à cordes
traditionnel anatolien d'un instrument
voilà qui est très importante dans la
culture anatolienne qu'on retrouve plus
largement de la culture persane au
caucase ateliers mais jusqu'aux balkans
c'est à ce moment que j'aime beaucoup et
c'est des chansons qui sont très très
belle je ne saurais que vous commandez
d'écouté ou jazz c'est des chansons en
turc mais qui sont loin des clichés on
va dire de la musique traditionnelle
c'est très beau enfin je vois là je suis
fade in jazz depuis des années et je
réécoute les mêmes chansons en boucle et
je ne m'en lasse pas ensuite tu es bien
en regardant mon historique sur mon
téléphone j'ai remarqué que je me suis
refait l'intégrale de john baez et 2
amalia donc du fado portugais je pense
que j'avais besoin en fait deux voix
féminines
je sais enfin de ses voix de femmes qui
ont chanté comme ça pendant des
décennies fin c'est comme si j'avais
besoin d'être entouré et soutenu par
elle dans cette période peut-être que
j'extrapole un petit peu mais voilà j'ai
réécouté tout leur discographie et je
les aime toujours autant donc si vous
n'avez pas écouté leurs chansons depuis
un moment je vous conseille jeu ensuite
au niveau de chansons plus de motivation
notamment pour motiver à faire du sport
ou le ménage et cetera j'ai beaucoup
écouté d'ouali pas même si j'ai
l'impression manon de la voir partout et
ça commence à me monter un petit peu
mais son album qui s'appelle donc futur
nostalgia et je trouve un super album de
pop avec vraiment ce côté un peu années
80 que j'aime beaucoup ma chanson
préférée c'est blake maroc
si jamais vous me direz vous laquelle
vous préférez est toujours la même les
musiques de motivation j'ai beaucoup
écouté aussi bomba estereo qui est un
groupe espagnol je pense et notamment la
chanson fuego qui me donne une énergie
enfin c'est à dire que c'est ça rentre
dedans quoi aussi mais voilà pour mes
chansons motivation et enfin j'ai
découvert grâce à radio radio chez voici
vous connaissez c'est un site internet
et une application collaborative qui
vous permet de vous localiser n'importe
où dans le monde sur un planisphère de
choisir le décennies et de générer
automatiquement une chanson d'un artiste
de ce pays et de cette époque et du coup
on peut que la bourrie en ajoutant des
chansons et cetera
ça fait des années que je vais sur ce
site un peu par période et là j'ai
découvert une chanson qui nous vient
donc une artiste somalienne qui
s'appelle army nakama ali j'espère que
je prononce bien est vraiment j'ai adoré
cette chanson et je les écoute hyper
souvent donc voila merci un radio pour
la découverte et enfin last but not
least je vais vous parler de deux
artistes que je suis beaucoup enfin
principalement sur instagram met
également un point dans sur youtube
donc la première c est qu tomov qui est
in artiste française dont l'âme beaucoup
le style en fait je la suis depuis est
vraiment de nombreuses années maintenant
et choquée elle a eu une évolution
artistique ces derniers mois qui est
assez phénoménal enfin je trouve qu'elle
est vraiment monté dans les vallées
pourtant j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé son
travail mais là elle est passée un
moment fait par l'abstrait et là elle
revient à du figuratif mais imprégné de
de l'abstrait justement de couleurs
extrêmement vive c'est chaleureux c'est
fort lassïnce turquie
que j'apprécie énormément alors que
voilà je ne sais pas elle a évolué
beaucoup ces derniers temps elle a aussi
une chaîne youtube donc ectfe où elle
documente sa vie en tant que freelance
en tant qu'artiste voilà c'est très
inspirant de voir comment elle en est
venue à réussir à se lancer à son compte
et aujourd'hui à bien vivre de son
activité artistique
ouais c'est en fait c'était moins grave
de pouvoir suivre des gens passionnés
par ce qu'ils font et qui produisent de
très belles choses et de l'art j'aime
beaucoup la suite et une autre artiste
que j'adore mais vraiment je fais une
fixette sur cet artiste
il s'agit de marianne taf thierry qui
est une artiste britannique co iranienne
je pense qu'on veut dire comme ça et
notamment elle a fait toute une série
d'illustrations de poèmes berçant qui
est mais sublime l'air et la ré ouvert
sa boutique et je me suis jeté dessus le
jour même pour me procurer un
une impression de l'une de ses oeuvres
bref je vous raconte vraiment d'aller
faire un tour sur seconde parce que
c'est juste retrouver et voilà pour ce
premier bilan culturel sur sociaux logos
donc pour le premier trimestre 2001 21
j'espère que vous avez pu découvrir des
autrices des artistes des créateurs de
contenu qui vous plairont et puis bah
voilà j'espère aussi que ça a amené un
petit peu de bonne humeur de légèreté et
de et dark dans votre journée de manière
générale dites moi si ce contenu un peu
plus posé vous intéresse ou si vous
préférez que je m'en tienne aux vidéos
sociologie je ne prendrai pas mal
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
a commenté m un like a partagé cette
vidéo voilà m'aider à faire vivre
sociaux lobos merci beaucoup d'avoir
partagé ce moment avec moi je vous dis à
très bientôt sur social au boss
[Musique]